JIM ACOSTA RIGHT NOW.
>>> YOU ARE LIVE IN THE CNN
NEWSROOM.
I'M JIM ACOSTA IN WASHINGTON.
WE BEGIN WITH TRAGEDY IN NEPAL.
AT LEAST 68 PEOPLE ARE DEAD IN
THE COUNTRY'S WORST PLANE CRASH
IN 30 YEARS.
SEARCH AND RESCUE TEAMS WERE AT
THE SITE AND WILL BE BACK THERE
AT DAYLIGHT ON MONDAY.
FOUR PEOPLE ARE STILL
UNACCOUNTED FOR, AND NOW THE
SEARCH FOR ANSWERS BEGINS.
THIS IS APPARENTLY JUST MOMENTS
BEFORE THE CRASH.
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS.
THE PLANE ROLLING ON ITS SIDE
WHILE FLYING LOW OVER A
POPULATED AREA, AND THEN THIS.
WE'RE FOLLOWING THE STORY, AND
WE'RE JOINED NOW.
THAT VIDEO SHOWS SOME REALLY
UNUSUAL MOVEMENTS BY THE PLANE
JUST BEFORE IT CRASHED.
WHAT MORE ARE YOU LEARNING?
>> QUITE A BIT.
YOU BARELY SEE SUCH VIDEOS JUST
BEFORE A PLANE CRASH, BUT THAT
WAS CAUGHT ON CAMERA.
WE BELIEVE THAT IS JUST MOMENTS
BEFORE THE PLANE CRASHED.
NOW, ACCORDING TO OFFICIALS, 68
BODIES HAVE BEEN RECOVERED.
FOUR YET TO BE RECOVERED.
AND SEARCH EFFORTS HAVE STOPPED
FOR THE DAY.
AND THEY WILL RESUME MONDAY
MORNING LOCAL TIME IN NEPAL.
THE PRIME MINISTER HAS ORDERED A
PROBE IN NEPAL, AND A PROBE
REPORT IS EXPECTED IN THE NEXT
45 DAYS.
NOW, OFFICIALS DON'T KNOW WHY
THIS PLANE CRASHED BUT WHAT WE
DO KNOW IS THAT MOST OF THE
PEOPLE ON THAT PLANE WERE FROM
NEPAL.
THERE WERE ABOUT 15 FOREIGN
NATIONALS ON THE PLANE AS WELL.
WHAT WE ALSO KNOWN IS THIS PLANE
TOOK OFF AT ABOUT 10:30 LOCAL
TIME IN NEPAL SUNDAY MORNING,
AND ABOUT 80 MINUTES INTO ITS
FLIGHT PATH, IT LOST CONTACT
WITH THE AIRPORT WHERE IT WAS
ABOUT TO LAND.
AND FELL INTO A GORGE.
NOW IT'S BEEN VERY DIFFICULT FOR
SEARCH AND RESCUE EFFORTS.
THE FIRST RESPONDERS HAVE BEEN
TRYING TO INSURE THAT THEY
RECOVER AS MANY BODIES AS
POSSIBLE, BUT IT'S A TREACHEROUS
TERRAIN, AND MOST OF THE PLANE
CRASHES WE KNOW THAT HAPPEN IN
THE SOMALIAN NATION DUE TO
INCLEMENT WEATHER AND THE
TREACHEROUS TERRAIN, WE ARE YET
TO UNDERSTAND WHAT REALLY WENT
WRONG HERE.
THERE'S A DAY OF MOURNING
ANNOUNCED MONDAY IN NEPAL, AND
YETI AIRLINES WILL ALSO NOT BE
FLYING ANY AIRLINES TOMORROW.
THEY'RE MOURNING THE DEATH OF AT
LEAST 68 PASSENGERS WHO WERE
ONBOARD THAT PLANE, JIM.
>> ALL RIGHT, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THAT UPDATE.
WE'LL STAY ON TOP OF IT.
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME.
AND JOINING ME NOW IS CNN
TRANSPORTATION ANALYST, MARY
SCHIAVO, WHO WAS THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL AT THE U.S. DEPARTMENT
OF TRANSPORTATION.
MARY, I WANT TO PLAY THIS VIDEO
AGAIN THAT APPARENTLY SHOWED THE
PLANE RIGHT BEFORE IT CRASHED.
OBVIOUSLY, THIS IS A PROBLEM.
WHAT STANDS OUT TO YOU IN THIS
VIDEO?
>> WELL, TWO THINGS.
FIRST OF ALL, IT DOES LOOK LIKE
A CLASSIC STALL, WHERE YOU LOSE
AIR DYNAMIC LIFT OVER YOUR
WINGS.
THE NOSE GOES UP, THEY LOOK TO
BE TRAVELING VERY SLOWLY, AND
THEN THE LEFT WING FALLS DOWN.
THAT'S A CLASSIC STALL, BUT WE
ALSO SAW THIS IN A CRASH THAT
CNN COVERED WAY BACK IN 2015, I
THINK IT WAS CALLS TRANS ASIA,
AND IN THAT CASE, THEY HAD ONE
OF THE ENGINES WAS SHUT DOWN.
AND SO THEY WEREN'T GETTING
ASYMMETRIC LIFT, BUT IT DOES
APPEAR TO BE A STALL IN THAT
PARTICULAR FOOTAGE THAT WE CAN
SEE IN THOSE FRAMES.
>> AND WHAT DO YOU THINK
INVESTIGATORS ARE GOING TO BE
LOOKING AT?
WE UNDERSTAND THAT THIS IS GOING
TO START UP AGAIN MONDAY MORNING
AT DAYBREAK.
WHAT WILL THEY BE LOOKING FOR?
>> WELL, FIRST AND FOREMOST,
THEY'RE LOOKING FOR THE COCKPIT
VOICE RECORDER AND THE FLIGHT
DATA RECORDER AND ALSO THE
OPERATIONAL HISTORY OF THE
AIRLINE AND THE AIRCRAFT.
THEY WILL FIRST AND FOREMOST GO
TO GRAB THE MATE NNS RECORDS TO
GET THE DOWNLOADS OF ALL THE
MAINTENANCE IN THE PLANE, THE
TRAINING RECORDS OF THE PILOT.
THERE'S INFORMATION ON THE
INTERNET THAT IT WAS AN
EXPERIENCED CAPTAIN OF 25 YEARS
AND A FIRST OFFICER OF ONE YEAR.
THAT'S A KIND OF AN UNUSUAL
PAIRING, BUT NOT NECESSARILY IF
THE FIRST OFFICER WAS STILL
GETTING INSTRUCTION.
AND ALSO, INTERESTINGLY, THE
U.S. FEDERAL AVIATION
ADMINISTRATION HAD JUST DONE A
REVIEW OF NEPAL AVIATION SAFETY
AS PART OF A PROCESS THE U.S.
DOES TO EVALUATE OTHER NATIONS
TO SEE IF THEIR AIRLINES CAN FLY
TO THE UNITED STATES.
THEY WEREN'T DONE WITH THEIR
EVALUATION YET, BUT THE NEPAL
AIRLINES COULD NOT TRAVEL TO THE
EU BECAUSE OF A PRIOR
INTERNATIONAL CIVIL AVIATION
ORGANIZATION REVIEW OF SAFETY.
AND THEY WEREN'T ABLE TO FLY TO
THE EU, SO THERE WAS A LOT GOING
ON IN NEPAL, AND LIKE I SAID,
THERE WAS HOPE WITH THE FAA
EVALUATION THAT THEY COULD SOON
BE FLYING OTHER PLACES.
BUT THIS CRASH WILL CERTAINLY
PUT A DAMPER ON THAT.
>> AND MARY, NEPAL IS OFTEN
REFERRED TO AS ONE OF THE
RISKIEST PLACES ON EARTH TO FLY.
VETICA WAS MENTIONING THE
TERRAIN A FEW MINUTES AGO.
TELL US MORE.
>> IT IS, BUT SO MUCH OF THE
TRAGEDY, SO MANY OTHER ACCIDENTS
ARE RELATED TO THE MOUNTAINOUS
TERRAIN, RELATED TO WEATHER.
SOMETIMES RELATED TO EQUIPMENT.
IT'S SOME CRITICISM OF THE
OPERATORS IN THE AREA FOR
TRAINING FOR THE CONDITION AND
THE MAINTENANCE ON THE
EQUIPMENT, ET CETERA, BUT
USUALLY WHEN THERE'S AN ACCIDENT
IN NEPAL, IT'S RELATED TO THE
TERRAIN AND THE WEATHER.
JUST PUNISHING WEATHER AND
THERE'S REALLY A LACK OF PLACES
IN CERTAIN PARTS OF NEPAL TO SIT
DOWN IF YOU'RE HAVING A PROBLEM.
BUT NONE OF THOSE FACTORS WERE
PRESENT IN THIS ONE.
AT LEAST THAT WE CAN TELL AT
THIS POINT.
THIS, I SAY, DOES LOOK LIKE A
CLASSIC STALL, BUT WE DID, CNN
COVERED YEARS BACK, ONE THAT
LOOKED VERY SIMILAR, WHERE IT
HAD LOST AN ENGINE.
SO THE COCKPIT VOICE RECORDER
AND THE FLIGHT DATA RECORDER
WILL GIVE THE INVESTIGATORS THAT
ANSWER.
THEY'LL PROBAB